Stephen ugh the guy who plays negan's
brutal right-hand man Simon on the
walking dead is a classic of that guy
you know you've seen him in something
somewhere but you can't just quite put
your finger on it so where exactly have
you seen that beautiful mustache before
here's why Simon from the walking dead
it looks so familiar mail-order bride
hugs official screen debut it came in a
cameo in the 1999 1.com flop giving it
up and he followed that with a guest
appearance on an episode of Law & Order
in 2000 but his first major role came in
the 2003 mob comedy mail-order bride
which featured Danny Aiello and The
Sopranos alum Vincent Pastore alongside
AAG in a movie the New York Times called
a strained incoherent fast abroad Rob
yeah brah Oh Rob
Hey everyone has to start somewhere
Grand Theft Auto 5 after more than a
decade toiling away in bit roles and bad
films like mail-order bride
aaaggghhh finally got his big break in
2013 by switching mediums he wound up
being cast to do voice work and the
motion capture for the hit video game
Grand Theft Auto 5
I'll played the fan-favorite bank
robbing math chef Trevor Phillips one of
the game's for three main characters and
he was pretty gratified the fans seem to
love the results of his work he told
BuzzFeed I have been so thrilled that
the GTA fans have responded so
positively to the performance they have
enjoyed his impulsive psychopathic
nature but have reveled in his humor
hey there Wade did you meet gay bro
interesting lady I should probably go
say hi I wouldn't seems that all doesn't
keep his unique brand of insanity
restricted to games though wanna do some
mouth move on to the next thing
public zombies unforgettable CBS cop
drama unforgettable which followed the
daily exploits of a detective with
photographic memory managed to get
canceled three times but not before ugh
popped up as a sleazy receptionist Larry
Yablonski in the episode a day of the
Jackie wearing an open shirt over a
string vest and a sporting a wild mess
of greasy hair this is the first time
and the Canadian actor showcase the kind
of unkempt crazy that Walking Dead fans
would later love to hate person of
interest I'll go meet another cameo on a
CBS procedural when he pops up with an
angry barfly in a season 3 episode of
person of interest
luckily for uggs character the
authorities happen to already be in the
bar because the Sailor he's fighting has
been tagged as a potential victim of an
upcoming crime so I'll go manage to get
off without soo bada beatdown broad city
alga made a memorable guest appearance
in Comedy Central's broad city in 2014
after SARS Ilana Glazer and Abbi
Jacobson managed to get logged out of
their apartment they call for a
locksmith and receive a lot more than
they bargained for when UGS shows up
Yolanda Yolanda so where is it you sleep
right which apartment George even though
the guest appearance lasted just a
couple minutes
aaaggghhh told the Calgary Herald that
he still gets recognized at airports for
the role of creepy locksmith Murdoch
mysteries based on the series of novels
by British Canadian author Maureen
Jennings Murdoch mysteries explores
crimes and 20th century Ontario through
the eyes of detective William Murdoch
aaaghh turned up on the show in season 8
episode glory days trimming down his
handle bar to a respectable shortness to
play Bat Masterson a legendary frontier
lawman who's trapped infamous bandits
Butch Cassidy and the Sundance Kid to
Toronto despite being a proud Canadian
hog played Masterson as a brash American
unimpressed by law enforcement north of
the border something he told Dogg shelf
he played upon purpose to prove a point
so many people come up to me and say
there is no difference between Canadians
and Americans well I disagree where are
your guns we don't carry guns north of
the border we rely on our wits ah
a lot of good your wits just did us
better call Saul another of AMC shows
that Argus worked on better call soul
has evolved from a Breaking Bad spinoff
into a show more than capable of
standing on its own two feet
star Bob Odenkirk is a linchpin of the
prequel success buddies given ample help
by the show's supporting cast in
particular Jonathan banks who plays
ex-cop Mike
and then a memorable scene from season 1
I'll got to be on the receiving end of a
short and painful life lesson from Mike
man that's a tough way to make a living
the escort dark indie romance the escort
is a story of two sex addicts brought
together by a mutually beneficial
arrangement a Down announced journalist
in need of a good story and a Stanford
educated prostitute in need of
protection from her clients one of those
clients yup it's OGG this time around
the oxygen backs down before getting
punched smart or beaten who sees an old
dog can't learn new tricks Westworld we
saw a lot of steven organ Westworld not
a lot in terms of screen time but a lot
of our himself as he adds a shot scenes
vacant for HBO's hit sci-fi series about
robotic host program to entertain guests
in an Old West themed amusement park his
character rebus is one such host a
villainous cowboy who plays a major part
in a narrative involving fellow hosts a
Delores Abernathy Old Spice ads in 2016
aaaghh began portraying the so-called
king of products Bob Giovanni in an
advertising campaign for the
hardest-working collection range a new
series of deodorant from retro men's
groomer Old Spice the company devised a
tongue-in-cheek plan to go back to the
days when they offered a money-back
guarantee if Old Spice wasn't up for the
job
resurrecting its 1-800 prove it hotline
and launching some hilariously bad
parody ad starring ugh so men can focus
on other more important things
thanks for watching click the loop icon
to subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
a check out all this cool stuff we know
your love tea